what's that believe nation I'm a little
bit sick today it's been a really rough
week which is the last video I need to
make for the week so I'm going to bring
everything I have to this final video as
we talk about the seven ways to get
started in your business with zero cash
one of the most common questions that I
get asked on my stream in my emails on
Twitter on YouTube is how do we get
started I don't have any money I don't
have an investor you need money to make
money you don't I'm going to show you
how to do it in seven different ways how
you can make money and start the
business without any startup capital
here we go okay so way number one is
start a service I think entrepreneurs
should always start a service over a
product whenever possible because it
does a couple things one when you're
starting the service you don't need to
invest into any gear you don't need
products you don't need a location you
can go to your clients right you're
investing your time your energy your
hustle but you're not investing your
dollars so it's great way to get started
and test something out before investing
money into it and as you start making
money then you can put it back in so
start with the service the other thing
that it does with the service is that it
gets you close to your customers when
you're selling a product you're not as
close to your customer but when you're
doing a service in your meeting with
them whether it's every week or every
month or record or whatever it is you're
getting close to them you're getting to
understand them you're getting their
money which is great you get cash flow
coming in without spending anything and
you're getting close to them you can
understand their needs and when you're
ready to then make the jump and self
product you have a ready space already
there so you can get that attachment to
them and when you're ready to go bigger
you already have that base to build from
[Music]
number two is use a print on demand
service so if you are going to any kind
of product make sure that it's a limited
production run and that you're not out
laying tons of cash this is a big
mistake that a lot of ultra cars will
make when the first getting started if
you want to make caps right I'm going to
make caps I want to be in the cap making
business great I got this six design
it's going to take off awesome if you
want to make real marching off of
baseball hats you need to order Todd
right you need to have 10,000 you need
to order 5,000 10,000 the challenge is
one that costs a lot of money right
you're going to take out a big loan or
take a mortgage on your house or sell
everything you have you know to get the
startup capital to be able to make that
initial purchase but the problem is you
don't know if that's going to sell or
not and it happens to so many people
they go for the bulk order because they
get the biggest price break and they
figure if I can sell all 10,000 of these
aren't going to make it rich great and
then you sell three because maybe your
design sucks because maybe you wouldn't
like it enough and so I would much
rather you use a print on demand service
where you are selling one hat of the
time and they're being printed 1/2 of
the time I mean shift one hat at the
time and their services allow you to do
this for a huge range of products
whatever you're trying to get out
themselves and why it's great is you're
not spending any money
the downside is you're not making as
much money right where if you buy 10,000
caps you might be making a 90% margin
where if you're selling one cap at a
time you may be making 5% or 10% you're
not making as much but what it allows
you to do is hat what I would love to
see you do is you're going into cast of
t-shirts whatever you're trying to make
test your concept see if it works see
people want to buy it or not right and
if you're selling these caps and you're
selling hundreds and hundreds of caps
that you say you know what forget this
print on demand service I'm going to
take the money under made from this and
I'm going to make my own order now it's
worth it it's not risky because you
really have them ready audience you know
who's going to keep selling so use the
print on demand services start to test
fit to build up an audience and then
when you're ready
make the jump because what I don't want
you to do is take out a big mortgage and
they get stuck with nine thousand nine
hundred and ninety two caps sitting in
your mama's basement because you
couldn't sell them and you took your
shot and now you're in debt for the rest
of your life don't do that use a Pringle
demand service number three is barter
and borrow listen as an entrepreneur is
never about the resources you have it's
always about how resourceful you can be
and so think about what you can barter
think about what you can trade think
about what you're really good at and
what you need help with and maybe you
could trade what you're really good at
with somebody else because they need
help with that you know if you're a
lawyer trying to get started but you
need a website trade some legal services
to a website designer they'll build your
website you've got your legal services
whatever it is right there's people who
need what you have and you need what
they have so find some way to barter as
an example after I sold my first
business I needed a new office and it is
a new thing to do and so I connected
with the venture capital company and
they had this amazing office at Yonge &
King which in Toronto was one of the
most prestigious addresses you can have
pretty much in a country I'd seen in the
country Canada I was there and I got the
space for free and I got to incubate my
next company out of there because I was
able to barter with the people who owned
that business I joined them I helped
them bring in deals at the same time I
got to incubate my business out of it
and so look for people who have what you
need and how you might drill to work
some kind of trade the other thing is to
borrow
before you go and buy something borrow
from somebody you know you get a
landscaping deal great for your first
gig don't go buy all the gear go blow
the gear from one of your friends
sitting in their garage and they're not
using it when I was getting started on
YouTube I did both I did barter and I
did borrow I had a friend of mine mark
Drager was actually featured in your one
word with certain of his company France
emedia he came in and in exchange for
promotion on the channel he filmed my
video so some of my very first videos
are has this intro like created by fancy
media or
in association with transmedia whatever
it is you got a lot of exposure on my
channel and in exchange he did the video
production and I was I was just the guy
in front of the camera and so that was a
great exchange as I wanted to go up and
do it myself the next step before I
bought a camera was I borrowed a camera
from a buddy of mine he was a bartender
and he did bartending tricks and flair
and he filmed a whole bunch of events I
said hey can I borrow your camera would
you mind I want to make my own YouTube
channel videos and see what happens and
I bought his camera for a gay right like
borrow they'll come by yet borrow tests
always find a smaller way to get started
in almost any industry the smaller way
to get started go and find that and then
pour it into your business you look at
Reynold and salsa yes I have a retail
location now yes it cost me six figures
in rent every year but how the business
was started was renting spots out of
gyms where we would pay 25 30 40 dollars
an hour to rip their gym space for an
hour and then fill it with students and
then we did more time right two hours
three hours at a time and then multiple
days right if you want to start a big
shop you don't have to go and take out a
five to ten year lease on a big shop
find somebody who already has some
retail location and ask if you can have
a tiny part of their store come in for
one day you're coming for every day for
a week come in for every Saturday for a
year like they take a piece of every
sale that comes in or whether they like
it just from a marketing because you're
bringing in awareness and people to the
store there's always guys is always a
smaller way to get started
Aurel farter think smaller things figure
at the same time right big goal crunch
it down into the next immediate steps
because what happens what happens to a
lot of you you have this big goal and
you think you have to take the huge
giant step that's my next step I got to
open up my store right it's my next step
we're going to take that big loader
that's my next step and then you do
nothing because you can't get the
capital until you stay here at the
bottom having done nothing and then
years and years and years and years go
by and you see other people making tons
of cash off of your idea and you freaked
out and complaining
was my idea I should be the one making
money off of that no because you didn't
take any action because the IP alone is
there enough you got to do the work and
so stop trying to take that big step and
instead doing nothing slow steps will
lead to that big step there is always a
smaller way to get started go and find
it and stop making excuses farther and
borrow number four is pre-sell and the
idea here is use services like
Kickstarter or use an email list or use
Facebook or whatever it is and start to
pre-sell your idea whatever product
whatever service whatever you have in
your mind that you think might cost you
ten thousand dollars or fifty thousand
dollars or whatever it is you think it's
going to cost you make a video about it
make a webpage about it right you can do
it yourself doesn't have to cost you
money or partner with people to help
make that happen and pre sell it so
before you actually go out and write
that book or before you go out and make
that t-shirt or before you go out and
launch that service you can pre-sell it
and see people are willing to buy it and
that just put money down and say listen
if I get a hundred people who will want
to buy this book I am going to write it
in here topic if I get a thousand people
who will pay for this specific ebook
then I'm going to write it or whatever
it is whatever your product idea is
right this new baseball hat right if I
get 25 people to commit to the first
sort of my baseball hat or a thousand
people whatever it is you need to make
your numbers work that's the whole point
of Kickstarter right it's great because
you're not giving up equity the only
when you're going to an investor you're
giving up equity in your business here
it's just marketing if you don't hit the
goal you don't make the product I mean
it sucks you didn't make the goal but
it's great because you didn't outlays
thousands of dollars and this idea
that's not going to take off because you
don't have an audience for it
so pre selling is a great great
fantastic amazing way to Glaus your
business without having to spend any
money
[Music]
number five is used free resources just
like I like bartering and trading and
borrowing I like free - I like finding
free ways to do stuff and so I would
always look to free even if it's not
ideal I would look to free before paying
for something right I want to start it
get anything up test it and then as I
start making some money then I invest it
back into growing so as an example there
was this there's this great games cafe
that opened up in Toronto well you pay
five to ten dollars to get into the the
location and then you play games and
then they sell food and it's a coffee
shop and it's a bar they have multiple
locations now when they started called
snakes and lattes instead of snakes and
ladders snakes and lattes anyway when
they started they didn't have a website
instead of investing into a website they
just did it on Facebook right did
everything on Facebook they had all the
Facebook as all of the social
connections all built in and already
ready to go when you're starting you
don't need a website does it help you
does it make you look more credible does
it you know allow you to do more
customized things 100% but you don't
need it start on Facebook just start get
something up get some attention get some
traction get your first dollars in and
then once you start making some money
you can figure it okay hmm
we're going to spend that I'm going to
spend that on and prove my product when
we spend it on business cards and we
spend it on an office car I'm going to
spend it on a new website we're going to
spend it when you're meeting people you
don't need an office having an office
should never be anything you consider
until you're making some money meet
people at their location meet people in
Starbucks I still meet people at
Starbucks I like an air of the office
you don't need to have an office stop
finding ways to spend money
anybody can spend money anybody can put
a budget together say hey I need a
million dollars we're gonna do this and
here's how we're going to spend it I'm
anything I'm sure you could find
millions of ways to spend a million
dollars you'll figure it out anybody can
spend money not everybody can make it
and so find ways to go free like using
Facebook like not having a business card
like not find office equipment any of
that stuff
with a coffee shop until you're making
some money
[Music]
number six is turn your job into a
client now I've always been a big
proponent of if you're going to have a
job don't look at it as just having an
income source yes you need to make money
that's great you need to be learning
from your job the point of taking a job
is to learn right so whatever business
you want to get into whatever this new
company you want to start the ideal
scenario is to find something has
already done that and go work for them
hard someone who has ten employees some
small company who you know built up is
bigger than you but not some giant where
the job you're going to get is tiny and
not helpful and then go work for them to
learn yes get paid but to learn and so
then how do you transition that job into
a business the two things that come to
mind are one that company that you're
working for could become your first
client it happens a lot where you need
to free up some of your time you don't
want to be an employee anymore and so
you become an independent contractor or
instead of going to work five days a
week you work three days a week or two
days a week or one day a week and maybe
it's not from the office anymore maybe
you work from home and you're not an
employee with the benefits and with all
the taxes anymore you're an independent
contractor running your own company and
so it gives you some money it gives you
your own client and you're in business
the second way to do it is to use some
of the opportunities that come through
this business that you're working at for
your own advantage
so you might be able to take one of the
clients that you're working on or you
meet somebody a networking event because
you're going there you're forming
contacts you're forming partnerships
right by being in the space you get to
make connection and you may see an
opportunity for you go to this
networking event and there's this person
that you meet and there's an opportunity
for you to work with them for them to be
your client and so you bring them on
board that could be your first client as
well and so these are from become an
independent contractor and splitting up
your week so you're not spending full
time at your job or or and or using the
connections that you build which is why
it's so important to have a job in the
industry that you want to build your
business and you're making contacts and
from there one of those becoming
earthquake and the number seven and find
a way to build a business without having
to spend any cash and it's an important
one build around a customer so business
is about providing value and I've talked
a lot a lot a lot a lot a lot about this
on this channel if you want to make
money have to provide value to your
clients having success in business is
going to come from combining two things
this is how you're going to provide
value right in this corner in this fish
is what you love doing right this is
your passion this is what you love doing
and in this corner and this face is what
the market wants what your clients want
your success will come by bringing these
two together because if you love doing
something but it provides no value to
anybody else it's going to happy a hard
time becoming successful entrepreneur
and if all you're doing is chasing
opportunity but you're not interested in
it you're never going to really be a
success you may make a few bucks but
you're never going to really be a
successful entrepreneur so you need to
combine what you love doing with what
people will pay for what the market
wants right there's been a ton of video
series that I put up that I love doing
but you guys didn't resonate with and
that I thought I pulled down some I do
keep up I recognize that this is really
just for me but if I had to build a
whole channel around it it wouldn't work
there's another ones that I could easily
go to right if I if I put 10 stupidest
things that Steve Jobs ever said right
10 biggest fights with Donald Trump
right if I started doing those kinds of
videos people would eat that up they
might be the most popular videos on my
channel right people would love that but
the idea of putting people down and make
people look stupid and just causing
controversy for the sake of fighting I
don't like it at all like it's not I
would never want to do that stuff it's
not part of who I am and so I'm not
making those videos even though there is
a demand because other people will do a
better job in any way than me
and I want to play in that game and so
combining what you love with what the
market wants is super important and
that's why you need to get close to
potential customers and build a product
or service around them so instead of
just saying here is my idea go buy or
don't buy be more collaborative think
about who potential customers would be
for your service or for your products
and go and talk to them ask them what
they think as to what their needs are us
and what their problems are us and what
their pains are and say hey if I made
this for you or if I came and did this
for you what is helped that be something
that you would pay for is that enough
value for you and if you get a yes and
it's worth it you would want to do then
your a business and if not then you need
to keep talking to people keep meeting
people make a list of all the potential
customers these are the kinds of people
who would buy for me and go understand
them so instead of just selling them
something saying here is a solution for
you it's talking to them and building a
business around them do something I did
really well in my very first business
even I mean in this business what's the
top tens most of the most of the videos
that we make on this channel are your
requests like what do you guys want to
hear who you guys want us to make a
video on what topic do you want to hear
from we collect it we think about it we
pick the ones that we like the most to
and then we start running with it in my
first business the biotech software
company all the features that we built
ended up being around what our customers
wanted you know you want this thing
added to the software great it's going
to cost you this amount of money to do
it and then we roll that feature into
the software for everybody else as well
do some custom development
we're not out money on the development
and then we can roll it out for
everybody else as well you want to
translate it into Spanish perfect it's
going to cost this amount of money to do
it provides it of value to them even if
that alone does that break even even
we're not making a profit off of that we
can roll it out to everybody else and
add more value to them and so building
your business around a customer is so so
so so important especially really
so those are my seven ways on how to
start a business without having any cash
I'm curious what do you guys think what
was your favorite rule what resonated
the most with you what are you going to
take from this and apply to your
business immediately you know I missed
something that you want to add is there
an 8 9 10 that you want to add to the
list leave it down in the comments below
I'm going to join in the discussion I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Wilford chin Wilford thank you so much
you're picking up a top of my book your
one word really really really really
means a lot to me so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is but love
of CSUN